but now we turn our attention tonight to
what we're calling
what is the big liberal extremist
socialist democratic party
lies and falsehoods this is the short
list tonight
now first there is a completely false
perception democrats
that they actually value freedom nothing
could be further from the truth
now while the classic definition of
liberalism is the willingness to respect
new ideas and
and the perception they support freedom
of speech their pro-choice freedom of
expression
well today's radical democratic party is
anything but
it's filled with leftists and status
they don't want
any freedom of speech and expression who
want to completely silence
cancel all opposition voices stifle
speech that they disagree with
and furthermore cancel anyone that dares
offend them
and naturally they applaud the efforts
of big tech to censor conservatives
not one prominent democrat has spoken
out
against this practice not one because
democrats
left this status they're also leading
the calls and they have for years
against a few of us here on the fox news
channel they would like us all
canceled and boycotted and shut down
or on radio conservative talk radio me
rush limbaugh the great one mark levine
and others need to be ripped off the
airways
and that's not all the byte
administration is already looking for
ways to prevent
any tough questions from the white house
press corps this is i'm not making this
up you have the deputy press secretary
telling politico we expect reporters
covering the white house to operate in
good faith
and organizations or individuals who
traffic in conspiracy theories
you mean like cnn abc nbc cbs and msdnc
propaganda all of them new york times
washington post
but those that lie and spread
disinformation will not be tolerated
wow they'll all be thrown out tomorrow
and we will work with white house the
white house correspondent association to
decide
how to handle those instances moving
forward
uh and who makes all of these decisions
that would be the same people that are
perfectly okay with not reporting a 100
biden laptop story in the new york post
you know the one that was true in other
words if you report something
they don't like or you don't buy into
their lies
their hoaxes their conspiracy theories
they'll just
cancel you silence you shut you down and
apparently kick you out
and they'll work with their allies in
the media mob and their allies in big
tech
to now walk you out of the white house
and completely cancel you
and the democrats perfect utopia there's
no difference there are no disagreements
no alternative opinions whatsoever
their twisted psychotic view of the
world they believe they hold the
monopoly on truth
and as we have long discussed on this
program they also believe
and they will tell you that they have a
monopoly on compassion
for working men and women in this
country which brings us to yet
another big radical leftist status
democratic
lie that is a lie that this is
definitely not the party that has a
monopoly on compassion
that's looking out for hard-working men
and women in this country
oh the person that said record low set
record low unemployment for
african-americans hispanic americans
asian-americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment african-american
youth unemployment
those records were shattered by yes as
acosta says
that would be president trump in exile
in order to appease his radical
socialist space
in one week in office the week the frail
joe biden has now been putting tens of
thousands
of our fellow hard-working americans
law-abiding tax-paying citizens
out of work their work has been canceled
all in the name
of this radical new green deal climate
change
socialist redistribution model that they
now endorse
keep in mind we are in the middle of a
pandemic
and because of a lot of democratic
governors and mayors
we've had draconian shutdown measures
and the unemployment rate
and the jobs that are failing well
extremely high
we have millions of americans out of
work through no fault of their own
and joe adding to misery is now
basically
announced well we're going to have
competition for the jobs that are
available by giving amnesty
to 11 million illegal immigrants
eventually
but with the stroke of a pen twice this
week joe biden has decided number one
to stop construction on the border wall
cancel
the keystone xl pipeline causing yes
thousands more to be laid off they
already got their pink slips we've
interviewed them
and further restrictions on american
fracking natural gas
will impact hundreds of thousands of
american jobs
keep in mind these are high paying
career jobs
with great benefits most of them are
union jobs
they fit a very specific skill set
and these workers now have been laid off
a lot of them making six figures
they are jobless but according to
coldhearted joe biden
his climate plan is about jobs
they don't have them because of you it's
not like you said okay we're going to
take this job and give you this job that
never occurred
they just lost their current job with no
hope
or reality of getting a job that's gonna
pay him a hundred grand a year take a
look
today uh is climate day at the white
house and uh
which means that today is jobs day
at the white house when i think of
climate change i think of the answers to
it i think of jobs
a key plank of our build back better
recovery plan
is building a modern resilient climate
infrastructure
and clean energy future that will create
millions of good
paying union jobs not seven eight ten
twelve dollars an hour but prevailing
wage
and benefits the guys in the energy
sector now getting paid on average a
hundred grand a year
you just laid them off joe uh you're
going to pay their mortgage you're going
to pay their rent you just destroyed
their careers their dreams their
livelihoods with promises millions of
jobs are going to be created
good jobs well how they're going to put
food on the table next week
pay the mortgage rent next week or pay
their truck or car payment
next week your unemployment insurance
joe's not going to cut it
and the competition right now for jobs
never been greater and because of
amnesty
and because of draconian shutdowns it's
going to drive
down wages you're taking away jobs now
you're promising big government
for solyndra the cold-hearted comments
of biden's cabinet are equally insane
you got biden's special climate envoy
john
kerry these americans need to find work
elsewhere
easy for him to say he's a
multi-multi-millionaire with his own
private jet
like you know the imaginary windmills
solar panel factories i don't remember
ever speaking out against the kennedys
off
cape cod or nantucket when they're going
to build windmills there but it would
have obstructed the kennedy view
you never criticized that and many of
these workers
as i said had six figure salaries uh
hey john kerry where do they go for work
on monday can they borrow
their jet to go interview take a look
the president of the united states has
expressed
in every comment he has made about
climate
the need to grow
the new jobs that pay better that are
cleaner what
president biden wants to do is make sure
those folks
have better choices that they have
alternatives that they can be the people
who go to work
to make the solar panels they were
making them here at home
that is going to be a particular focus
of
the buildback better agenda
next week they got no job to go to john
i know you're married into a lot of
money i know you fly around the world on
your private jet
leaving your big fat carbon footprint
pretty much everywhere you go
by the way john kerry maybe you need to
scrap heap your private jet i think it's
time to sell the plane
because that makes you a lying hypocrite
and john kerry to stand there with a
straight face and callously as climate
envoy and argue that americans
that now will not be working next week
they should lose their jobs because of
his radical global warming new green
deal socialist agenda
as he uses his private jet as a lot of
these cabinet members of joe biden are
they going to give up the government
jets that you pay for the american
taxpayer
they've got fleets of them are they
going to they're going to agree to give
them up i doubt it
kerry isn't the only biden official with
a cavalier attitude either
by the way all against working americans
they're now
devastated by yes the pink slips that
they got and no job to go to
high paying career jobs in the energy
industry
they don't have a job on monday where
are they going to go
monday who's going to put food on the
table who's going to pay their rent
their mortgage
anyway take a look at other callousness
so for those workers the answer is
somebody else will get a job
the answer is that we are very eager to
see those workers continue to be
employed in
good paying union jobs even if they
might be different ones
you just took their job and you didn't
give them another job pete
now the former mayor of south bend
indiana doesn't exactly have the wealth
of experience or knowledge
and pete you just got a new job they had
good paying union jobs
you put the insane socialist green new
deal ahead of every one of these
hard-working great american workers
and their families and pete's colleague
jennifer granholm
well she at least was a little bit more
honest by saying and stating that of
course
yeah jobs are going to be sacrificed for
the democrats radical green agenda
all in comrades take a look
i'm just curious how a long-term ban
consistent with the president's goal of
unifying
our country and putting americans back
to work and helping our economies
grow how is that all consistent i think
the
president's plan of building back better
which would create more jobs in
energy clean energy than the jobs that
might be sacrificed but i will say this
no job we don't want to see any jobs
sacrificed
how does a welder and a pipe bidder and
a rig worker
tell me how does the that those skills
very specific learned over decades in
some cases
how do they translate to windmills you
got to help me out here
and perhaps she's more honest but just
as dumb in supporting this
dumb madness and adding insult to injury
those who were forced to sacrifice their
careers guess what
you're also going to be facing higher
taxes as well as higher energy costs
and these biden geniuses now oh on top
of the predictable
rise in heating rates for your home and
gas at the gas pump
they're eyeing a brand new gas tax
biden's pick for commerce secretary even
announced
tax hikes on the middle class yeah
probably going to be necessary to pay
for joe's new green deal socialism
agenda
windmills solar panels hate to tell you
it's not cheap
you might remember solyndra now to joe
promise higher taxes on you
the amer american people mid middle
class
the people that truly make this country
great every day when he was hiding in
his basement bunker during the campaign
in the candidate uh campaign protection
program of the media mob and the big
tech mob
i don't recall promising to raise taxes
on the middle class
matter of fact if memory serves me well
it was quite the opposite
let's see if the videotape proves me
right
this is about everybody paying their
fair share
so no new taxes four hundred thousand
dollars in taxes there would be no need
for and will you be raising taxes
uh on small businesses you're talking
about look
you have ninety percent of the
businesses out there
are mom and pop businesses that are out
there that are making
employ less than fifty people there'll
be no raising taxes
nobody making under 400 000 bucks would
have their taxes raised period
bingo let's get people back to work
okay you just took away their jobs and
jennifer granholm you're a point decent
you're going to raise taxes on the
middle class
but i guess you consider anyone that has
a job still middle class
what joe biden did then was lie directly
to your face
i thought the media bob didn't like
lying from politicians
either way we told you so we predicted
all of this
by the way none of this will improve the
climate
the world will still consume oil and gas
but now
less of it will be sourced from america
instead
all the oil and gas the lifeblood of the
world's economy
they're gonna have to ship it on boats
and trains and trucks
let's see we'll be importing uh energy
again from the middle east countries
that hate our guts
china a hostile regime russia hostile
regime
hostile actor putin president xi the
iranian muellers
other countries venezuela wow no epa in
these countries
wh by the way and similarly the paris
climate accords
they don't charge china the same as they
charge us china is considered a
developing nation we're the only suckers
that pay the real freight
i guess we're going to make all those
hostile regimes against us rich again
we'll make them great again and america
once again will be dependent on foreign
energy
which compromises our national security
not a good idea
pollution will likely get worse we will
pay more in prices on the way
and to sum up we're going to pay more at
the pump pay more to heat our homes
we'll pay more in taxes and our enemy
and hostile regimes around us will all
get rich
and they'll be prospering they're doing
backflips tonight
tens of thousands of americans are
losing high-paying career jobs russia
china iran
other middle eastern countries doing bat
back flips and going giddy tonight
here's my prediction mark my words this
will not
end well on top of this biden has a plan
to keep democrats
in power in perpetuity oh i warned you
about this too
it's happening and that includes by the
way a bill that would grant statehood
to washington d.c therefore ensuing to
ensuring two democratic
senators uh from d.c
maybe puerto rican statehood puerto rico
statehood is next
and we have two more democratic senators
in perpetuity
now biden is now staffing a commission
to analyze
supreme court reform okay i was right
again let me translate that for you
you are talking about court packing you
want to figure out a way to control the
u.s supreme court and overthrow a branch
of government in other words
an unprecedented dangerous power grab
and in other news these same radical
democrats are
falsely accusing president trump of
citing an insurrection
and the sham unconstitutional
impeachment trial begins in a few short
days
we already know the outcome president
trump will be acquitted
so they will now officially be wasting
your money and your time
and enough we get it you hate president
trump
it's actually amazing isn't it when you
think about it donald trump has this
unique ability
to live in these people's minds
every second minute hour of every day he
lives there for years and he's not in
office and he still lives there
and now today some in dc oh they're
figuring out that they lost
in terms of a conviction we'll get them
this way
we'll do censure of the president now
republicans we for once get a backbone
we for once not buckle not capitulate
not give in we say he's not in office
enough stop wasting our time and our
money
and if they're gonna do that censure
then do it to chuck
and do it to joe and do it to kamala and
do it to maxine waters i'm going to take
trump out tonight
and then you can do it to everybody else
that has said
insightful insurrection-like language
stop legitimizing you republicans you
weak ones
this psychotic rage focus on your job
we're in the middle of a pandemic
there are millions of americans out of
work democrats once again proving my
point
they don't have compassion there's no
awareness
there's no empathy and sadly
hard-working americans
as we unfortunately predicted rightly
are now paying the price jobs are lost
but there's promises of jobs here there
and everywhere
well they're not ex they're non-existent
at this moment